today our immigration system is broken
and everybody knows it President Obama
vowed to create a path to citizenship
with more than four million undocumented
immigrants living in the United States
for five years or more Ashford was
brought to America when she was four
years old she mostly lived in the
shadows until her grandmother who
visited every year from Mexico passed
away and she couldn't travel to the
funeral without risk of being found out
and deported the president talked about
Astrid and others like her but what he
didn't talk about were the immigrants
coming from further south from countries
like Honduras and El Salvador people
desperate for not just economic
opportunity but for safety people in
need of asylum perhaps that's because
the president's plan to deal with those
people is to lock them up and send them
back these are people who are fleeing
very real very concrete examples of
violence state violence cartel violence
it all started in the summer of 2014
headlines screamed about a border crisis
as thousands of unaccompanied minors
flooded into the country and protests
occurred in southern border towns the
Obama administration asked Congress for
879 million dollars to provide more than
6,000 new beds in detention centers
Congress denied this request but
Homeland Security forged ahead and
opened two new centers anyway including
this one in Carnes Texas
certainly a lot of unaccompanied minors
came over but these folks are ending up
in family detention centers are the
opposite of unaccompanied minors if a
child comes with their parent and
particularly if a child becomes with
their mother they end up in a prison
like setting they end up in at one of
these detention camps one of the many
families living in the sterile building
in rural South Texas includes Maria
Estella Marquez and her three daughters
Melissa carbon and Jacqueline ages 15 13
and 11 they fled El Salvador after
members of a street gang began extorting
Maria for profits from her street
vending business Homeland Security
denied us access to Maria and her
daughters but we did talk to their
attorney Virginia Raymond right before
they left and two men associated with
Amadas who had been threatening the
mother and who had also attacked one of
the girls on her way from home from
school came into their house and pulled
money Estella back by her hair like this
put a gut pistol right up against her
head very tightly and in front of the
three daughters made a number of threats
as if y el peor dia de media senti que
todo Eva garden is a moment I felt like
the world was going to end that day
don't even know when they got there or
how they got him they just opened the
door very forcefully my two sisters
screamed and I hugged them and they
started to cry one of them grabbed my
mom by the hair really hard and put a
pistol right up against her head when I
saw that I just felt like my whole body
shook and I covered my sister's eyes he
looked at me with such a sinister look I
will never forget those horrible eyes
and he told me that if my mom didn't
feel like giving them the money they
demanded they will rape me and my
sisters and my mom last of all so that
she would see everything they did to us
I felt so awful at that moment like I
wanted to report what had happened to
the police but even if I had done that
it would have been useless because the
police in my country are corrupt they
work for those guys that's the reason we
immigrated to this country we are
terrified just thinking about going back
in these three Central American
countries that were seeing most people
from there is government consent or
acquiescence there are places and there
are times when the law enforcement and
modest or kaya di co cho are very
tightly closed that there are members of
these criminal organizations in
government positions in law enforcement
positions and so what we know is that
you know many times when people report a
crime or act of violence to the police
those st. police are either involved
directly themselves or have associates
who are in America the government grants
asylum to those persecuted for being
part of a protected group and the
persecution must come from the
government or a group that the
government cannot control a dangerous
gang uncontrollable and sometimes
abetted by government officials have
persecuted Maria and her daughters who
are particularly vulnerable because
they're part of a targeted group namely
single females it seems like a classic
asylum case but for Maria Estella and
her daughters it's not the status of
many astellas there's no legal barrier
to getting deported tonight right I mean
there she could get deported any time as
far as the girls go on the asylum
officer will make a determination about
whether or not they have a credible fear
of returning to El Salvador what do you
fear would happen if these girls end up
getting sent back
salvatore it is a tough question um one
that keeps me awake at night I mean I
think that their fear of being raped and
then killed or at least raped or at
least killed or you know or some of them
getting rape or losing a sister to to
murder or rape and murder I think it's
very likely I think their fear is a very
realistic one some Americans protest
immigrants just showing up at the border
jumping the line as it were just
expecting to be let in I welcome
everybody to the United States but come
the legal way but the fact is when
you're fleeing persecution and seeking
asylum just showing up at the border is
exactly what you're supposed to do it's
important to remember that these are
people who have come here in the legal
way you can't seek asylum from where you
are you have to come to the border and
say I I'm here to seek asylum you know
that's what these people have done
they've put their faith in our system
when people knock on your door and they
are fleeing abuse the United States is
obligated morally and legally to let
them in the policy of locking up asylum
seekers isn't losing steam anytime soon
just weeks ago another small Texas town
called dilly opened a new Detention
Center and it's the largest one to date
it's important to keep in mind like how
big these numbers are at the start of
this year we only had a hundred family
detention beds artesia opened and they
were holding six or seven hundred people
there then Along Came Carnes where
they're holding 532 people and they want
to expand it now and then we heard about
dilly and they want to hold 2400 people
there there's really nothing like this
in
united states history except for
Japanese internment these are people who
want to work who are peaceful loving
people who are embarrassed to say the
obscenities that people have said to
them they are people you would want to
be friends with they really are and they
don't deserve to be sent back to be
raped and killed by virtue of their
status as young women and a single
mother in a country that does not value
them and where the government cannot or
will not protect them